hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and today I'm
launching a new series on how to start a
fashion business the fashion business is
very sexy it's very fun it can be very
profitable but it's also filled with
failure and can be very costly so many
people who want to start in the fashion
business take out our loan mortgage
their homes the finance the initial
inventory and end up with a garage or
basement full of t-shirts and hoodies
and being in debt for the rest of their
life so this series is about how you can
start a successful fashion company and
do it the right way today's lesson is
you have to find your passion from a
very young age Calvin Klein knew what he
wanted to do be in fashion you see when
his parents immigrated to the United
States they were pretty poor they didn't
have a lot of money or connections his
father set up a grocery store and Calvin
worked there part-time during evenings
and weekends instead of playing with the
other kids are joining sports teams
Calvin Klein didn't have a lot of
friends and decided to stay home he
wanted to teach himself how to sketch
and sew designs and he wanted to
accompany his mother when she went on
trips to buy discount clothing as he
grew up his passion for fashion deepened
he went to school to study to learn how
to be a fashion designer and he became
increasingly upset that there were no
unique original designs coming out of
America it seemed like all the Americans
wanted to do was copy and rip off the
European designs he wanted American
fashion to be different and he was
willing to lead the way it was that
passion not just her making money but
for having a positive impact that led
him to become a Multi multi
multimillionaire
you see passion is so important because
if you're not deeply passionate about
your business you're going to quit it's
going to get too hard you're going to
get a lot of roadblocks thrown in your
face and you have to be crazy in love
with them enough to want to keep going
because most people would just give up
facing those odds
when Klein was trying to get started in
the fashion business his father actually
sold his grocery store to his friend
Barry Schwartz Schwartz turned it around
and made it a highly successful
enterprise and invited Calvin to come in
and be a partner at the time Calvin was
struggling he wasn't having any success
in the fashion industry yet he was
struggling and trying to break through
he felt like he tried everything
he could and he wasn't getting any
momentum with his clothing designs and
so he thought long and hard about taking
that offer and taking over the grocery
store he set up an appointment with his
dad to talk about the idea and he was
ready to tell his dad I'm ready to join
the family business and what his dad
said shocked him he told Calvin that
entering the grocery store business
would be a tremendous mistake he told
them that he didn't really understand
everything he was doing and what he was
studying but that he was giving up on
his dream too soon and so Calvin stuck
with his passion continued building in
fashion and ended up building an empire
the point here is that if you're in this
business just trying to make money
you're gonna go broke you have to really
want it you have to really feel it it
has to keep you up at night it energize
you to want to keep going if you're
trying to get into the business just as
a get rich quick scheme then try
something else but if you really love
fashion you really want to have an
impact you really want to make a
difference then stay tuned because in
the next couple of weeks we're going to
have a lot of fun believe if you guys
like this video you want to see more and
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you soon
if you want more entrepreneur goodness
check out the link to my newsletter
below see you there
you